rise of the Tomb Raider may have been an  xbox one exclusive for a bit but it  seems like most of you were waiting for  the PC release super data released its  January 2016 sales report and according  to the research group Tomb Raider sold  nearly three times the amount of copies  in its first month than in the same time  frame on Xbox one Square Enix is  probably pretty stoked about that  rise of the Tomb Raider launched the  same day as fallout 4 which super data  said heard its numbers on top of that it  launched on PC during a slower month  Microsoft is still pleased with its  numbers though Tomb Raider did sell over  a million copies on Xbox one all at all  rise of the Tomb Raider performed very  well that's good news if you're a Lara  Croft fan and for the fans who still  haven't played her latest adventure the  game is planned for a ps4 launch later  this year when it gets an official date  we'll have all the details at GameSpot